[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDRE SUSANO PINTO:
Hello, my name is Andre,
and I'm a software
engineer in Zurich.
I'm the technical lead for
the TensorFlow Hub project.
TensorFlow Hub is a
library and a repository
for reusing machine learning.
We open-sourced it last
year, and today I'll
give you an update
on the project.
Let's start by talking about
when you'd want to use it.
If you have problems
collecting enough data
to train your
models from scratch,
then transfer learning
is a technique for you.
You can use Hub to make it easy
to reuse parts of models that
were trained on large parts--
on large amounts of data.
Additionally, since it's so
easy to reuse computations
and weights, it becomes
possible to leverage features
without having to learn how to
fit them into neural networks.
So images, text, and
videos are features
you can use with a
single line of code.
You might also have
encountered problems
where code bases
become really coupled
and experimentation
becomes slower over time.
By defining an artifact that
does not depend on code,
Hub allows for more
maintainable systems,
similar to how libraries have
helped software engineer.
So the main concept is these
pre-trained building blocks
that we call modules.
Typically, we start by
training a large model
with the right
algorithm and data.
From this large
model, we're just
interested then into a part
of it, which is reusable.
This is typically a bottleneck
layer or some other distributed
representation.
Then we can package them
into a SavedModel that
defines this computation and
the weights that were trained,
and no longer depends
on the original code.
You can share this
artifact via the file
system, web servers, cloud.
Then you can bring this module
back as a piece of a new model
to solve a new task.
Since the model is defined
by TensorFlow primitives,
you can fine tune its
weights and adjust them
to your problem.
So what's new?
For the last few
months, we've been
making it even easier to use.
This concept of saving a part
of a model and then loading it
back is getting integrated
right in the core of TensorFlow.
We have added
SavedModel features
that make it possible to share
more than just signatures.
And with eager execution,
it becomes even easier
to select the part of a
network that gets exported.
Let's look at a few examples.
In TensorFlow 2.0, we can
load a module with hub.load.
We can also use
tf.savedmodel.load
if the model is already
on our file system.
Due to eager
execution, once loaded,
we can call it right away.
Additionally, due to
the new capabilities,
you can now share any
object which is composed
of TensorFlow primitives.
So in this case, text_features
has two members--
__call__, which is a TF
function, and embeddings,
which is a TF variable.
We're also really excited
that we added support
for polymorphic functions
when we serialize TF functions
on SavedModel.
This will provide a
more natural interface
than we had before
with signatures.
For example, here we see an
image representation module
being loaded and then being
used in inference mode,
or being used during training
mode where batch norm is on.
Or when it's on,
we can also control
its-- some of its parameters.
And all of this is just
baked by TF graphs,
so we no longer need
to be selecting things
here and there.
We just get all the
API that looks very--
very, like, patterned.
Additionally, we have
added a new symbol--
hub.KerasLayer.
This makes integrating hub
modules into a Keras model
easier.
In this example, we see how it
is to build a text sentence--
a sentence classification model.
So we have three layers.
The top layer-- this Keras
layer, which is the NNLM--
is a layer that receives
sentences as inputs
and outputs a Dense
representation.
Then we have a dense layer
and a classification layer.
Since the Keras layer--
this NNLM layer-- includes
text preprocessing on it,
we can just feed sentences
straight into our model.
We never had to define
the logic for it.
Additionally, if we wanted
to try other text models,
we could just
change that string.
They'll be as easy to try
like the latest research.
So the status is we
have released a 0.3
version of TensorFlow Hub.
It has these two new
symbols we just saw--
hub.load and hub.KerasLayer.
And they are usable
in TensorFlow 2, both
in eager and graph mode.
To let you preview
this functionality,
we have published some
modules in this format.
And we-- the next
steps for us is
to backport existing modules.
A bit more practical now--
Google AI and
DeepMind teams have
been sharing their resource
with you on tfhub.dev.
This was already
launched last year,
and there are some new modules.
And we're going to have
a look at some of those.
One of the most popular was
the universal sentence encoder.
This was a module that
encoded short sentences
into a dimensional
vector that could
be used for many
natural language tasks.
Recently, the team has added a
cross lingual version of this.
So sentence with
similar meaning,
independent of the
language-- they'll
end up in points close together.
What's exciting about
this is that now you
can learn a classifier
using English data,
and then you can run
it on other languages.
We have also added image
augmentation modules.
The policies to augment images
were trained by reinforcement
learning on tasks
such as ImageNet,
and they have been shown
to transfer to new tasks.
An interesting thing is that
you could grab this module,
and you could grab one of the
image representation modules,
and you could string
them together.
In this case, the image
augmentation module
would reduce the amount of
data by data augmentation
and the image feature
vector by transfer learning.
And there are many more.
We have BERT module
for text tasks.
We have object
detection modules,
BigGAN modules for
controlled image generation,
I3D kinetics for video
action recognition, and more.
Some of these
models' architectures
were specially designed
for low resources.
Additionally, we
have been working
making modules more integrated
with other pieces of TensorFlow
ecosystem.
We have a command line
utility to convert Hub module
into a TFJS model.
Hub models can be used
together with AdaNet,
which is a library for AutoML.
And they can also be
used inside TF transform.
So if you want to try it,
you can go to tfhub.dev
and you can search for modules.
Most of them include
the link where
you can see them in action.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]